und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend die eigentümlichste und
medial aufsehenerregendste meldung
dieses tages war die von einem
angeblichen giftanschlag auf den
russischen oligarchen abramowitsch das
ist der dem der fußballclub chelsea
gehört was weniger bekannt war dass er
zumindest teilweise an verhandlungen mit
den ukrainern teilnahmen auch in deren
delegation sollen mitglieder nach einem
treffen anfang märz auffällige symptome
gezeigt haben von ukrainischer seite
wird das aber dementiert und auch der
us-geheimdienst glaubt nicht an eine
vergiftung vielmehr lässt sich dazu im
moment nicht sagen wir schauen zunächst
auf den parallel laufenden
wirtschaftskrieg zwischen dem westen und
russland
moskaus rubel förderungen haben die
g7-staaten heute mit einem deutlichen
net beantwortet erklärungen dazu von
laura ba mit das nein der g7
energieminister kam in einer gemeinsamen
stellungnahme klar und deutlich man
werde sich von russland nicht erpressen
lassen
zu spalten ist offenkundig aber das
sieht man an dieser großen
geschlossenheit und entschlossenheit wir
lassen uns nicht spalten und die antwort
der g7 staaten ist eindeutig die
verträge werden eingehalten
aktuell laufen die bezahlungen von
gaslieferungen so bislang bezahlen die
eu die usa und großbritannien ihre
gasrechnungen in euro dollar oder pfund
das geld geht an russische energie
lieferanten wie gazprom anschließend
müssen die 80 prozent bei der russischen
zentralbank in rubel eintauschen doch
das will putin nicht mehr man muss
politisches manöver so verstehen dass er
die stabilisierung des rubels auf den
internationalen finanzmärkten etwas
erleichtern will momentan versucht dass
die zentralbank zu tun die ja die
devisen bekommt von gazprom die aber den
sanktionen unterliegt und nur beschränkt
handlungsfähig ist
eigenmächtig hatte der russische
präsident versucht die spielregeln für
gaslieferungen zu ändern zu den kreml
unfreundliche staaten sollen nur in
rubel bezahlen dürfen
dann hätte das geld bei einer nicht
sanktionierten russischen bank wie der
sberbank erstmal in rubel getauscht
werden müssen die sberbank hätte da
nicht mit sanktionen belegt devisen
handel mit ausländischen banken
betreiben dürfen das hätte den rubel
gestützt und die sanktionen unwirksam
gemacht
durch die reaktion des westens zu sagen
wir lassen uns nicht darauf ein haben
wir den ball jetzt erst mal zurück zur
coaching gespielt und jetzt wird
abzuwarten bleiben wie er als nächstes
reagiert die antwort des kreml sprechers
heute kam prompt
modestudium dass wir das glas nicht
umsonst liefern werden ist eindeutig das
können wir mit absoluter sicherheit
sagen in unserer situation ist es kaum
möglich und wenig sinnvoll für ganz
europa den wohltäter zu spielen
auch droht paskov jetzt mit einem
embargo
es gibt einen markt in südostasien im
osten ohne zweite werden die
ausfallenden aufträge kompensiert werden
bis mitte der woche hat präsident
vladimir putin der russischen
zentralbank zeit gegeben um seine
ankündigung umzusetzen
da fragen wir doch noch mal nach bei
unserem korrespondenten
christiansen in moskau wie ernstes dass
zu nehmen diese drohung jetzt quasi
umgekehrt den gashahn zuzudrehen
ja schon vor der entscheidung der g7
hatte der kreml sprecher peskow das ja
schon mitgeteilt dass wenn europäische
länder jetzt keine ruh bezahlen wollten
für das gas dann würde es das eben auch
nicht umsonst geben und eine ebene
tiefer im parlament äußerte sich ein
abgeordneter der auch mitglied des
wirtschaftsausschusses ist der drohte
ganz offen mit einem lieferstopp also
russland weißen vor allem wladimir putin
weiß welches druckmittel man da in der
hand hat und das versucht er jetzt aus
zu spielen und vielleicht erinnern wir
uns noch mal an die diskussion um die
gaspipeline nord stream 2 er wurde von
russland immer wieder verneint dass man
mit der pipeline und auch mit dem
russischen gas politischen druck ausüben
werde und heute in europa sehen dass
viele ganz anders
zugleich erhöhte kreml der deag remmel
weiter den den druck nach innen
dazu passt die meldung dass nun auch die
unabhängige zeitung nowaja gaseta ihre
arbeit einstellt
ja die zeitung hat das heute auf ihrer
internetseite angekündigt die noch
funktioniert in russland viele andere
medien seiten funktionieren dann nicht
mehr heißt es nur kurz und knapp man
werde nicht mehr berichten so lange die
und das steht in anführungszeichen
zeichen spezielle militär operation
laufen werde so wird das genannt in
russland oder muss in russland genannt
werden von den medien was gerade in der
ukraine passiert und das ist natürlich
ein großer schlag noch mal für die
medienwelt hier beziehungsweise so groß
ist sie gar nicht mehr das war die
letzte große freie stimme die es noch
gibt und die den konflikt bis zu diesem
neuen fake news gesetz eigentlich recht
gut aufbereitet hatte auch in ihrem
online medium das ist jetzt vorbei also
die russinnen großen die jetzt wirklich
noch nach informationen zu der aktuellen
lage in der ukraine suchen die müssen
schon sehr genau gucken und das ist
nicht einfach und dazu vielleicht auch
noch interessant heute zu erwähnen
russische journalisten haben ein
interview mit us-präsident zealand ski
geführt und da hat die
medienaufsichtsbehörde ganz klar
verboten das russische medien dieses
interview veröffentlichen ein medium
medusa das nicht nur in russland tätig
ist hat es doch gemacht das zeigt ganz
deutlich der druck geht nicht mehr nur
gegen die medien insgesamt sondern auch
gegen konkrete inhalte und eine
begründung die wurde von ross kommen hat
so von der medienaufsichtsbehörde nicht
mitgeliefert
dankeschön christian für diese
informationen aus moskau
dem kreml ist offenkundig auch sehr
daran gelegen dass der eigenen
bevölkerung nicht bewusst wird was ihre
armee im nachbarland tut
mario pohl vor dem krieg einer
wirtschaftlich aufstrebende hafen und
universitätsstadt davon ist jetzt
praktisch nichts geblieben nach
ukrainischen angaben gibt es in der
stadt bereits über 5.000 todesopfer
aus der distanz zerstören stadt am boden
zu erobern so wirkt derzeit die
russische kriegsstrategie greifbar jack
fasst die aktuellen entwicklungen im
ukraine krieg zusammen
etwa eine halbe million menschen lebten
hier vor den bomben mario pohl die stadt
schwer getroffen von russischen truppen
umzingelt ohne wasser strom gas
aufnahmen bilder irgendwann vom
wochenende sie dringen nur verzögert und
spärlich durch die luftangriffe haben
wenig stehen lassen indem leben noch
möglich ist dennoch sollen immer noch
160.000 menschen in der stadt sein so
der bürgermeister heute war keine flucht
möglich
die erniedrigung die jeder bewohner von
mario pohl wegen der russischen
besetzung durchmacht ist in worten nicht
zu fassen unsere wichtigste aufgabe
heute und daran arbeitet auch unser
präsident ist die vollständige
evakuierung der stadt
der 33 tag des krieges wieder einer mit
toten verwundeten bomben zerstörungen
gleich an mehreren orten soll es wieder
angriffe der russischen armee gegeben
haben in luft
auf und rund um die hauptstadt kiew
schwere explosionen so ukrainische
medien und auch das ukrainische fahnen
wieder dort wo bis vor wenigen tagen
russische truppen standen nikolajew etwa
im süden der ukraine russische
streitkräfte hätten sich zurückgezogen
zurückgeblieben die zeugen schwerer
kämpfe mehrere kleine orte will die
ukrainische armee mittlerweile
zurückerobert haben darunter auch ihre
pin bei kiew
wir haben heute gute nachrichten heute
haben wir fünf befreit jetzt führen wir
eine aufräumaktion durch
die militärische lage insgesamt unklar
denn die russische armee führung betont
weiter militärische erfolge jeden morgen
vermelden sie ihre angriffe die
erfolgreichen der sprecher des
verteidigungsministers zählt dazu die
abschüsse auf mehrere flugzeuge und
zahlreiche militärische stellungen
insgesamt 36 sollen es gewesen sein
währenddessen erneute verhandlungen
zwischen den kriegsparteien auf
arbeitsebene auf neutralem grund in
istanbul morgen militärische politische
lösungen sind kaum zu erwarten die
können nur von den präsidenten beider
länder gefunden werden aber bis zu einem
treffen putins lenski ist es noch ein
weiter weg denn noch vorsichtige signale
heute auch über fragen von
gebietsabtretungen mögliche neutralität
ich verstehe dass es unmöglich ist für
russland das gebiet komplett aufzugeben
das würde zu einem dritten weltkrieg
führen mir ist das bewusst deshalb sage
ich ja es gibt einen kompromiss kommen
wir dorthin zurück wo alles begonnen hat
und wir werden versuchen die frage um
den don was zu klären
präsident putin hat sich nie geweigert
präsidenten ski zu treffen das einzige
was er für wesentlich hält eintreffen
muss gut vorbereitet sein kein reiner
meinungsaustausch hieß
das leiden die flucht der menschen geht
unterdessen unvermindert weiter
angesichts solch unfassbare gewalt und
zerstörung und der ungewissheit was noch
alles kommt und wie viel es städte die
russische armee noch in schutt und asche
legen will wundert es nicht dass dieser
krieg schon jetzt die am schnellsten an
steigende flüchtlingszahlen seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg ausgelöst hat das
un-flüchtlingskommissariat schätzt dass
um sechseinhalb millionen innerhalb der
ukraine auf der flucht sind und weitere
knapp vier millionen bereits ins ausland
geflohen die innenminister der
europäischen union beraten heute darüber
wie europa damit umgehen soll aus
brüssel florian neumann
es gibt dieses wort vor dem die
innenminister rinnen und minister die eu
heute zurückschrecken das wort ist
offenbar verbrannt quote eine
verbindliche quote zur verteilung von
geflüchteten in der eu das war seit 2005
10 die ständige ständig vergebliche
forderungen deutscher innenminister
weil es eine frage der gerechtigkeit ist
das wenn europa sich dieser humanitären
verantwortung stellt dann muss das die
ganze europäische union sei nur dass
nicht die ganze union mit ziehen wollte
und dass der streit darüber europa fast
zerbrechen ließ sieben jahre später
einen krieg diesmal in der direkten
nachbarschaft und die aktuelle
innenministerin klingt wie eine
erzieherin diesmal auf die sanfte tour
versucht
warum scheuen sie wurde dem boden wort
zurück ich glaube sie haben jetzt eine
solidarität innerhalb der eu staaten
erreicht und auf diesem erreichen wollen
wir aufbauen wir wollen jetzt nicht
starten verschrecken immer noch kommen
täglich zehntausende geflüchtete aus der
ukraine in der eu an einige davon heute
am berliner hauptbahnhof
es sind schon jetzt dreimal so viele wie
2015 doch anders als 2015 können sich
diese geflüchteten frei in der eu
bewegen und die meisten bleiben in der
nähe der heimat wie hier in polen in den
ländern osteuropas die 2015 gegen quoten
sturm liefen und jetzt
wir fragen andere länder und wir haben
das laut im eu rat gesagt wenn jemand
mehr geflüchtete aufnehmen will dann
müssen spezielle angebote für sie
vorbereitet werden
das in einem monat fast drei prozent der
bevölkerung tschechiens gekommen ist ja
also jetzt rechnen wir natürlich auch
mit gewisser solidarität von den anderen
ländern
solidarität ja aber bloß nicht
verpflichtend statt einer quote
beschließen die minister einen index er
soll zeigen welche staaten besonders
belastet sind
bei diesem index schauen wir uns an wie
viele ukrainische und andere geflüchtete
ein mitgliedsstaat aufgenommen hat aber
ich denke es ist wichtig zu wissen dass
alle staaten mehr tun als gewöhnlich wir
stehen vor der größten flüchtlingskrise
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
doch was wenn 18 millionen menschen
kommen wie manche erwarten nach der
sitzung eine kleine portion skepsis
also wir werden das sehen wie weit wir
damit kommen ich find die index bildung
gut dass ich ein besserer weg aber wir
brauchen das sich ja auch mehr
verbindlichkeit du hast ein klein wenig
so klingt wie das wort das noch keiner
in den mund nehmen will das von der
quote für die verteilung von
geflüchteten
die private spendenbereitschaft ist
jedenfalls weiter enorm
126 millionen euro sind bereits für das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
zusammengekommen zu dem auch die caritas
gehört wenn auch sie helfen wollen hier
noch mal die kontodaten ebam de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
nothilfe ukraine alle infos auf unter
spenden punkt zdf.de oder im zdf text
auf seite 8 190 und jetzt die
nachrichten von heinz wolf und zunächst
zur corona situation und zur
umstrittenen frage wie es mit den
schutzmaßnahmen weitergeht
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach gab
nach beratungen mit seinen
länder-kollegen bekannt dass die
bisherige rechtsgrundlage für viele
bundesweit geltende beschränkungen wie
geplant am kommenden wochenende auslaufe
er forderte die länder auf zu handeln
und wenn nötig die sogenannte hot spot
regelung zu nutzen sie erlaubt strengere
schutzmaßnahmen wenn eine überlastung
des gesunder gesundheitsversorgung droht
wegen steigender infektionszahlen gilt
in der chinesischen wirtschaftsmetropole
shanghai seit heute ein strikter
lockdown in einem überraschenden schritt
hatte die stadtregierung die maßnahme
erst gestern abend angekündigt mit
weiträumigen ausgangssperren und
massentests in der bevölkerung soll die
ausbreitung des virus gestoppt werden
eine kurzfristige ankündigung löst sie
hamsterkäufe aus öffentliche
verkehrsmittel wurden eingestellt china
verfolgt in der pandemie eine null kovac
strategie
das landgericht hagen hat einen
17-jährigen wegen eines geplanten
bombenanschlags auf die hagener synagoge
verurteilt zu einer jugendstrafe von
einem jahr und neun monaten auf
bewährung
er hatte noch keine konkreten schritte
zur umsetzung seines vorhabens
unternommen wie das gericht mitteilte es
ordnete eine vorläufige unterbringung in
einer einrichtung für der kinder und
jugendhilfe an
der un sicherheitsrat hat die in
afghanistan herrschenden taliban
aufgefordert das recht auf bildung für
alle zu respektieren und die schulen für
mädchen ohne weitere verzögerung zu
öffnen die taliban hatten entgegen ihrer
zusage mitgeteilt dass schülerinnen ab
der siebten klasse bis auf weiteres
nicht am unterricht teilnehmen dürfen
die taliban sind seit mitte august des
vergangenen jahres wieder an der macht
in afghanistan
israel die usa und vier arabische
staaten haben sich bei einem gemeinsamen
gipfel auf eine verstärkte
zusammenarbeit geeinigt vor allem mit
blick auf den mit israel verfeindeten
iran der israelische außenminister rapid
bezeichnete das treffen als historisch
die partnerschaft solle auf basis von
technologie religiöser toleranz sowie
einer kooperation in sicherheit und
geheimdienstarbeit fußen
nach der saarland wahl ist die spd nach
wie vor in jubelstimmung absolute
mehrheit alleinregierung ein drei
parteien parlament
das mutet fast schon exotisch an und
auch wenn alle berliner sozialdemokraten
betonen wie sehr das doch die leistung
der saarländischen spitzenkandidaten
rehlinger sei ein teil des erfolges
verbucht man schon auch bei sich
oder wie kevin kühnert gestern sinngemäß
sagte die bundespolitik habe zumindest
nicht gestört was bei den
sozialdemokraten in der tat keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist ganz anders
das bild bei der cdu da kann die
parteispitze gar nicht genug abstand
wahren zum wahlverlierer tobias hat das
desaster möge bitte als ein rein
saarländisches verstanden werden andrea
maurer mit der wahlnachlese herr hans
müsste da sein vielleicht machen sie die
videokamera kurz an so sieht ein
politisches ende aus noch bevor es
ausgesprochen ist
der abgewählte ministerpräsident ist
schon gar nicht mehr nach berlin
gekommen lässt sich zur cdu pk am
vormittag zu schalten irgendwann streikt
auch seine kamera am abend verkündet
hans dann in saarbrücken seinen
rücktritt vom parteivorsitz
mir war das nach der wahlniederlage des
gestrigen abends ein bedürfnis
verantwortung zu übernehmen der eindruck
den hans abgang hinterlässt dass die
bundes-cdu ihn nicht ausreichend
unterstützt ihn schon vor der wahl in
einer internen sitzung abgeschrieben hat
wir haben die saarländische cdu in der
tat wirklich nach kräften unterstützt da
braucht sich niemand von uns einen
vorwurf zu machen es hat hier intern
eine diskussion gegeben wo wir dastehen
zu einem zeitpunkt wo die umfragen schon
ziemlich schlecht waren das ist hier aus
einer internen sitzung herausgetragen
worden ich bedauere das sehr das wäre
nicht nötig gewesen
während der cdu parteichef seine partei
heute darauf ein schwert nicht depressiv
ins landtagswahl ja zu gehen
stimmungshoch bei der spd und ihrer
künftigen ministerpräsidentin kaum zu
überhören der seitenhieb gegen die
ziehen wir in der spd stehen zusammen
das unterscheidet uns in diesen tagen
von unserer konkurrenz die in den
wahlkämpfen diewald wahlkämpfenden auch
alleine gelassen hat alleine gelassen
wenn auch anders die linkspartei von
ihrem mitbegründer oskar lafontaine kurz
vor der wahl ist er aus der linken
ausgetreten hat ihr an der sah den
todesstoß versetzt von 12,8 auf 2,6
prozent der frust offensichtlich
personelle konsequenzen folgen offen ich
werde jetzt mal sagen gerade bei uns
brennen von schnell zu füllen und
relativ hoch aber
wir haben uns im september entschieden
dass wir die verantwortung übernehmen
und die weiterentwicklung der partei die
linke auf den weg bringen das
wahlergebnis alleine erklären muss hier
heute ungewollt der saarländische
kandidat der afd das im zertifikat von
parteichef kuba ist abgelaufen er kommt
nicht rein zwei
pkw zu errungen sind mit 5,7 unter den
erwartungen
geblieben im großen und ganzen im
gesamtumfeld muss ich aber sagen dass
wir doch irgendwo dahingehend zufrieden
sind wichtig ist was den landtag blieben
nicht im landtag die beiden ampel
parteien fdp und grüne dort ist heute
viel von der speziellen situation im
saarland die rede es gilt signalwirkung
für den bund zu vermeiden
im saarländischen landtag wird die cdu
sich die oppositionsbank nun mit der afd
teilen müssen die spd will mit absoluter
mehrheit allein regieren
und wenn er sie in berlin schauen wir
noch mal auf die cdu da sieht man ja
wirklich so maximale abstands wahrung
zum wahlverlierer von berliner seite und
der tenor alles rein saarländisch keine
bundespolitische bedeutung
aber kann es sich die cdu führung
tatsächlich ganz so einfach machen das
ist ja ein bewährtes mittel
landtagswahl niederlagen zu einer
regional sache zu erklären das haben
andere parteien auch schon so gemacht
allerdings ist es bei der c aktuell so
dass das in einem widerspruch zu einer
selbst gewählten erzählung steht als
friedrich merz zum parteivorsitzenden
gewählt worden ist hat er in seiner rede
direkt danach noch einmal daran erinnert
dass drei nicht ganz einfache jahre
hinter der partei legen und eine schwere
niederlage bei der bundestagswahl und
dann hat er seiner partei wörtlich
zugerufen aber diese zeit liegt jetzt
hinter uns mit anderen worten er hat
sich selbst ins zentrum eines aufbruchs
gestellt und zum motor dieses aufbruchs
gemacht und viele seiner anhänger haben
ja auch fest daran geglaubt dass es den
märz effekt gibt ein schärferes profil
für die partei dass sich dann natürlich
auch in mehr zustimmung bei wählerinnen
und wlan ausdrückt die saarland wahl hat
jetzt gezeigt ganz so automatisch
funktioniert es nicht und das wirklich
märz das selbst auch weiß das hat sich
heute in der pressekonferenz auch schon
angedeutet da hat er eben die saarland
wahl zur regionale sache erklärt hat
gesagt ein wichtiges datum für die
bundespartei sei die
nordrhein-westfälische landtagswahl und
das ganz große ziel die ganz große erste
bewährungsprobe das sei erst die
europawahl 20 24 das ist noch eine weile
hin bis dahin will er viel schwerer
aufbauarbeit leisten das heißt er nimmt
die erwartungen jetzt schon ein bisschen
runter dass dieser aufbruch effekt den
er noch vor kurzer zeit geschworen hat
jetzt sehr schnell kommt und vielleicht
heißt das auch für anstehende
landtagswahlen wer für die cdu
landtagswahlen verliert sollte die
mitverantwortung nicht zuerst in berlin
suchen danke chefin die analyse konnte
viele infos analysen und videos zur
saarland gibt es bei uns wie immer auch
online auf zdf heute und jetzt nochmal
heinz mit dem blick auf die finanzmärkte
an diesem montag die preise für häuser
und wohnungen in deutschland sind im
vergangenen jahr erneut kräftig
gestiegen besonders stark im jahresende
und das frank bethmann nicht nur in den
metropolen nein inzwischen ziehen die
preise auch im umland an denn
insbesondere für familien ist wohnraum
in den großstädten kaum noch zu bezahlen
so sucht man vermehrt in den ländlichen
regionen was dort die preise treibt ein
und zweifamilienhäuser in dünn
besiedelten ländlichen kreisen
verteuerten sich zuletzt zwischen
oktober und dezember noch einmal
deutlich um fast 16 prozent kaum weniger
stark der preisanstieg über 13 prozent
bei eigentumswohnungen
insgesamt mussten interessenten im
vergangenen jahr für den kauf von
wohnungen oder häusern im schnitt elf
prozent mehr bezahlen als noch 20 20 die
sorgen vor steigenden hypothekenzinsen
einerseits aber auch die angst davor
dass künftig am bau alles noch teurer
wird als es ohnehin schon ist treibt die
deutschen in immobilien sie flüchten in
betongold fachen damit die inflation
ohne es zu wollen weiter an
deutschlands teuerste pflaster bleiben
nach aktuellen berechnungen bei den
metropol münchen wo der quadratmeter
kaufpreis bei bestandswohnungen auf im
schnitt
9732 euro gestiegen ist der bundesweit
erste landkreis mit quadratmeterpreisen
von 7
1977 euro ist nordfriesland mit den
nordseeinseln sylt amrum und föhr die
bundesbank warnt seit jahren vor blasen
auf dem immobilienmarkt doch kurzfristig
so scheint es ist keine trendwende in
sicht frank bethmann vielen dank gerne
die gewerkschaft verdi hat nach mehreren
warnstreiks in den vergangenen wochen
für das private sicherheitspersonal an
deutschen flughäfen eine tarifeinigung
bekannt gegeben demnach wurde bei einer
laufzeit von 24 monaten eine dreistufige
tariferhöhung vereinbart die für die
einzelnen lohngruppen unterschiedlich
hoch ausfallen für das laufende jahr
zwischen 4,4 und
7,8 prozent
der langjährige zdf sportchef dieter
gruschwitz ist gestern im alter von 68
jahren gestorben
fast 40 jahre war er im sport
journalismus 21 davon beim zdf in seiner
ära als zdf sportchef von 2005 bis 2017
erhielt gruschwitz zahlreiche
auszeichnungen gleich zweimal gab es den
deutschen fernsehpreis einmal für die
fußball wm berichterstattung
2006 für die er mit jürgen klopp
roßmeier ein expertenteam aufstellte
dass die zuschauer begeisterte und auch
nach der leichtathletik-wm 2009 nahm er
den preis entgegen
zum schluss noch ein kurzer rückblick
auf die vergangene nacht in hollywood
auf die oscar-verleihung
zurück zu altem glanz wollte man nach
jahren der kritik nach der pandemie
endlich wieder eine glamouröse feier
überschattet von dieser szene komiker
chris rock scherzt über die raspelkurzen
haaren von jada pinkett smith sie
allerdings leidet an krankhaftem
haarausfall ihr mann superstar will
smith verliert die fassungen schlägt zu
[Applaus]
ein erklärungsversuch
ich möchte mich bei der akademie und den
anderen nominierten entschuldigung liebe
lässt einen verrückte dinge tun
die academy stellte klar dass sie gewalt
nicht billige
jessica chastain es beste schauspielerin
und jane campion beste regisseurin für
den eindringlichen western the power of
the dog okay
anrührend geht es im besten film zug
oder
es geht um die tochter gehörloser eltern
die sängerin werden möchte ein
überraschungssieg
das science fiction epos tun räumt sechs
preise ab zwei davon gehen nach
deutschland spezialeffekte gerd netzer
und
für musik hans zimmer der von seinem
oscar in einem hotel erfuhr im
bademantel
[Applaus]
ja das war es von uns mit hollywood
gleich auch weiter im montagskino
mission impossible mit tom cruise oder 0
30 meldet sich dann christopher wehrmann
mit dem heute schnell update es machen
ist der sehsinn
[Musik]
genannt unter klarem himmel sinken die
temperaturen südlich der donau heute
nacht auf 0 grad sonst bleibt es unter
den wolken milder bei 8 bis 4 grad und
in norddeutschland kann es etwas regnen
morgen trübt saharastaub den
sonnenschein und am nachmittag ziehen
hier von südwesten einige regenwolken
auf in norddeutschland liegt eine
kaltfront die wolken lockern spätestens
nachmittags von schleswig holstein aus
auf bei nordwest wird es wird kalt da
oben in norddeutschland liegen die
höchsttemperaturen nur bei 8 bis 12 grad
in süddeutschland geht es dagegen bis 21
grad rauf aber das wird sich ändern
bis zum ende der woche liegen die
temperaturen in deutschland weiter nur
noch zwischen 1 und 9 grad es wird also
deutlich wechselhafter und auch kälter
jetzt am wochenende ist der märz
sonnenschein rekord für deutschland
geknackt worden seit aufzeichnungsbeginn
war es noch nie so sonnig in schleswig
zum beispiel gab es mehr als doppelt so
viel sonne wie üblich
also ein starker monat für die
sonnenenergie eine optimal also nach
süden ausgerichtete dach solaranlage
erzeugt in einem sonnigen jahr rund 6000
kilowattstunden das ist mehr als eine
fünfköpfige familie im jahr verbraucht
bei der anzahl der dachanlagen ist in
deutschland noch viel luft nach oben
denn derzeit werden nur etwa zehn
prozent der geeigneten dächer von ein
und zweifamilienhäusern für die solare
stromerzeugung genutzt guten abend